Luis receives a gift card worth
$25 to an online retailer that
sells digital music and games.
Each song costs $1,
and each game costs $2.
He wants to buy at least
15 items with his card.
Set up a system of inequalities
that represents this scenario
and identify the range
of possible purchases
using a graph.
So let's define
some variables here.
So he's going to
buy music and games.
So let's let m equal the number
of songs he buys, and let g
be equal to the number of games.
Actually, just so
it's more intuitive
let's let s be the
number of songs.
And let's let g be equal to the
number of games that he buys.
So they give us some
information here.
They say that he wants to buy at
least 15 items with this card.
So that means that
the total number
of items, the number of songs
plus the number of games,
have to be at least 15.
So this sentence
right here tells us
that s plus g-- that's
the total number
of items-- it has
to be at least 15.
So it has to be greater
than or equal to 15.
It can be 15 or
larger, it could be
16, 17 18, so on and so forth.
It also tells us that he
has a gift card worth $25,
and each song costs $1
and each game costs $2.
So he can't spend
any more than $25.
So how much is he going
to spend as a function
of the songs and the games?
So each song costs $1.
So he's going to spend
the number of dollars
times the number of songs.
So if he buys 10 songs
is going to spend $10.
Plus, for each game,
he is going to spend
$2, plus 2 times
the number of games.
So if he buys five
songs and five games,
the five songs are going to cost
$5, 5 times 1, plus 5 times 2
for the games, plus 10.
So it's going to be $15.
So this is how much he
spends on songs and games.
I could have put a 1
out here for dollars,
but this is how much he spent--
or 1 for it's $1 per song.
But this is how much he spends
in dollars on songs and games.
And he only has a
gift card worth $25.
The total amount he
spends has to be less than
or equal to $25.
He can spend exactly
$25 if he has to.
He just can't spend $25.01.
So we have a system
of inequalities here,
and now we can
essentially graph them.
And so to graph
them we just have
to pick one something to
go on the vertical axis
and the horizontal axis.
And actually I'm only going to
draw the first quadrant here
since he's only going to buy
a positive number of songs
and games.
So let's let the songs
on the vertical axis,
and let's let the games
on the horizontal axis.
And then what I like to do
is, I like to express it
in terms of-- or if I'm
putting s as the vertical axis,
I like to solve for
s, so it kind of
goes in the traditional
slope intercept form.
So this first thing up
here, if we subtract g
from both sides of this,
we get that the songs
have to be greater than or
equal to negative g plus 15.
And then this one over
here, if we subtract 2g
from both sides-- I'm going
to do it in that same magenta
color-- if we subtract
2g from both sides,
so that we isolate
the s on the left,
we get s is less than or
equal to negative 2g plus 25.
And now we can try
to graph these,
and we could just
look at points.
Or we could look at the slope
intercept of the boundary line.
So over here, if
he buys no games,
then s is going to be-- well
just think about the boundary
line here.
So the boundary line for
this constraint over here
is going to be s is equal
to negative g plus 15.
So if he buys no games
he will buy 15 songs.
So let's make this
5, 10, 15 songs.
So the s intercept,
we could say, is 15.
If he buys no games
he'll buy 15 songs,
based on that constraint.
Now what happens if
he buys no songs.
If he buys no
songs, then you have
0 is equal to
negative g plus 15,
or you could say that
g is equal to 15.
So if he buys no songs then he's
going to have to buy 15 games.
So it's 5, 10, and 15.
So that would be a point
on the boundary line.
And we're actually going to
include the boundary line,
because it's greater
than or equal to.
So I'll draw a solid line here.
So this is our boundary
line, but it's not just
the boundary line.
It's not s plus
g is equal to 15.
It's s plus g has to be
greater than or equal to 15.
Or s is greater than or
equal to negative g plus 15.
So when you look at it this
way, you see s for any g,
negative g plus 15, is
going to hit the line,
or it's going to hit right at
the boundary line for the s.
But it's that s
and any of the s's
that are greater, so we're
going to be above the line.
And if you just
want to make sure
you can verify that
we're above the line.
You could try something that's
on the other side of the line,
maybe 0, 0.
0, 0 definitely doesn't work.
0 plus 0 is not greater
than or equal to 15.
And if you try something
out here like 15 comma
15-- 15 plus 15 is 30, which
is greater than or equal to 15.
So we feel pretty good that it's
this whole area above the line.
And now let's look at
this second constraint.
The boundary line is s is
equal to negative 2g plus 25.
So once again, the s intercept,
or if g is equal to 0,
s is equal to 25.
So we go to 20, and then 25.
If g is 0, s is 25.
And then if s is 0, what is g?
If s is 0, we get 0 is equal
to negative 2g plus 25.
We can add 2g to both sides.
You get 2g is equal to 25.
You can divide both sides by 2.
You get g is equal
to 25/2, which
is the same thing as 12 and 1/2.
So if s is 0, g is 12 and 1/2.
Something like this-- 12
and 1/2 would put us-- well
it's actually going
to be-- that's 5,
so 12 and 1/2 is going to be
right in between these two
guys.
It's going to be
right over there.
And once again we're
including the boundary line
because it's less
than or equal to,
so we'll include
the boundary line.
So I'll draw a solid straight
line, just like that.
That's supposed to
intersect right over there.
And then you can think
about it two ways.
You could just say, well, for
any g, negative 2g plus 25
will put us on
the boundary line,
and we want all the s values
that are less than that.
We are going to be
below this line.
And you can verify it.
Take some points that's on
either side of this magenta
line, 0, 0 should work.
If you have 0 plus 0, that
is less than or equal to 25,
so that works.
15 comma 15 shouldn't work.
15 plus 2 times 15 is 3
times 15, so that's 45,
and that's not less
than or equal 25.
So stuff out here above the
magenta line won't work.
Stuff below the
magenta line will work.
Now the range of combinations
of songs and games
that will actually
work are the overlap
of these two inequalities.
The way we've visually
drawn it right here,
they only overlap right
over here, this region
that I'm shading
in here in blue.
But it will include
the boundaries
because both of
those constraints
were-- included the equal.
This is greater
than or equal to,
this is less than or equal to.
So it will include
the boundaries.
So any combination
of songs and games
that fit in this
boundary right here
will satisfy his constraints.